The Incredibles is an awesome kids movie
about a family of superheroes but the
rider snuck in lots of adult jokes and
some are really inappropriate stay tuned
to hear a pretty shocking joke that
definitely wasn't for kids do you love
all things Disney don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give us a
big thumbs up now we'll tell you about
the 10 funniest adult jokes in
Incredibles you might have missed
peeping tom The Incredibles wastes no
time in sneaking and adult jokes the
movie starts off the day mr. incredible
and elastic girl get married mr.
incredible is almost late to their
wedding because he's fighting crime he
saves a man who was jumping off a
building this grumpy dude sues mr.
incredible saying he never wanted to be
saved this starts a series of lawsuits
and protests against superheroes during
the news report several newspaper
headlines flash across the screen one
accuses a super with x-ray vision of
being a peeping tom we're sure most kids
didn't notice this since it was flashed
across the screen so quickly and we hope
most kids don't know what a peeping tom
is let's just say this super was accused
of using his powers for looking at
things he shouldn't can you say invasion
of privacy just the thought of someone
with x-ray vision looking our way makes
us want to dress in layers
let's just hope whoever this guy with
the extra awesome vision was using his
powers for good and not for
inappropriate reasons still we can
understand the concern some of the
citizens in this movie would have if you
think about it x-ray vision is pretty
creepy getting busy we think you'll
agree that syndrome is kind of a creep
seriously even as a kid he's way too
obsessed with mr. incredible and even
stalks him a kid like that surely can't
turn out normal he was totally born to
be a villain it has nothing to do with
mr. Incredibles rejection when syndrome
lures mr. incredible to a secret lair
seriously who lives near a volcano and
captures him Elastigirl and the kids
have to come save him syndrome is
shocked to see that mr. incredible
married Elastigirl
he's even more shocked to see they have
children with powers he says mr.
incredible got busy
Crowley Disney it's totally normal for a
married couple to have kids there's
nothing inappropriate about that
the Disney had to make it awkward and
use the phrase get busy we know the
writers wanted to make syndrome have the
most off-putting personality ever but do
they really need to squeeze in an adult
joke for something completely innocent
if it made us uncomfortable can you
imagine how poor dash and violet felt
they're already being attacked by an
evil genius they only have to think
about their parents that way gross
Edna's jab at mr. incredible Edna mode
is one of the funniest characters in The
Incredibles fashion designer two
superheroes she's blunt sarcastic and
maybe a little crazy after years of
having to design regular fashion she is
ecstatic at the opportunity to design a
new modern superhero suit for mr.
incredible she's so excited she takes it
upon herself to design suits for the
whole family
Elastigirl is shocked to find out that
Edna has created a new suit for her
husband she discovers that Bob lied
about losing his job and that she has no
clue where he is
Edna mentions to her that men at Roberts
age are often unstable prone to weakness
adults know she's not just talking about
donning his superhero suit again Edna is
hinting that Bob is being unfaithful to
his wife as part of a midlife crisis but
with the way she says it it could also
be a double entendre sometimes there is
a certain weakness that affects
middle-aged men and it is definitely not
kid appropriate regardless of the double
meaning the constant allusions to
infidelity are not exactly
family-friendly maybe Disney was just
trying to make it relatable to
middle-aged parents watching the movie
with their kids we sure hope this didn't
upset anyone who could relate too much
Froese owns annoying wife before he was
Nick Fury samuel l.jackson starred as
another superhero Frozone he's got some
pretty cool powers he can freeze water
instantly even just from the vapor in
the air Frozone is mr. Incredibles best
friend every Wednesday they relive the
glory days and find crime to fight by
listening to the police scanner Frozone
wants to quit when he sees the giant
robot destroying the city he can't help
but jump back into superhero action he
presses a super cool remote that reveals
a secret part of his bedroom only to
find that his super suit is missing he
hasn't got time to go to Edna fern
he shouts at his wife and they begin a
shouting match that is all too relatable
for married couples his wife seems
totally oblivious to the destruction
happening outside she is far more
concerned with the dinner she's had
planned for two months Frozone is so
annoyed and runs out of the house as she
reminds him that she is the greatest
good he's ever going to have the
annoying angry wife trope might seem a
bit offensive nowadays but it is often
featured in adult comedies plus fighting
over silly things is definitely a part
of marriage we know in the end Frozone
and his wife really love each other
attracted to power Mirage is syndromes
flirty sidekick who lures mr. incredible
to their volcanic mansion she sends mr.
incredible a message and tells him she
is part of a secret branch of the
government after mr. incredible defeats
the robot for the first time the two
have a thing jested dinner mr.
incredible asks why on earth her boss
would build a mansion in a volcano
doesn't that seem like a terrible idea
she says that her boss and she are
attracted to power Bob tells her that
seems very unstable and she replies that
she thinks it's just misunderstood
mirage isn't necessarily talking about
superpowers here she's talking about
something you might find in Fifty Shades
of Grey but not here even among adults
the type of power she's attracted to is
considered taboo but a lot of people
think that certain types of activities
are just misunderstood later on when
syndrome calls her sweetheart after
basically telling mr. incredible to kill
her we can see exactly what type of
relationship they have and at least in
this case mr. incredible is right their
relationship does seem very unstable and
unhealthy
we're glad Mirage realizes Syndrome is a
bad guy with a capital B she redeems
herself and helps The Incredibles go
fight her former boss pinching rear ends
this next adult joke is way more obvious
than the last one after mr. incredible
loses his job and goes to fight
syndromes robot he thinks he's working
as a superhero once more he totally
finds his mojo again there is a
hilarious montage showing him getting
back into shape spending time with his
children and once again being a devoted
husband
really happy to see that he's still
madly in love with the elastic girl but
did Disney really need to be quite so
obvious and inappropriate while helen is
carrying laundry bob pinches her on the
backside to flirt with her then she uses
her stretch powers to return the favor a
few seconds later we see her pull him
back in the house on his way to work to
do things we can't exactly talk about
here they're married and in love while
it may not be wrong it certainly doesn't
need to be shown in a kids movie there
are plenty of more innocent ways to show
that there rekindling their romance
right maybe a candlelit dinner let's
just hope that Dash and violet were at
school when all this was happening think
that's too inappropriate keep watching
to find out the most obvious adult joke
in The Incredibles
just watching TV mr. incredible has a
really bad habit of lying to his wife he
tells her that he and Frozone go bowling
every Wednesday when they're really
moonlighting as superheroes he lies to
her about losing his job and lets her
think that he was promoted and he
definitely lies about being recruited by
mirages with all the hints that mr.
incredible is being unfaithful to
elastic girl it's no surprise that the
writers made an adult joke about it when
Bob clears out his suitcase after being
fired he sees a suspicious envelope
inside is a digital message from Mirage
the elastic girl calls him for dinner
and asks if someone is in there he acts
very suspicious and tells her he's just
watching TV it seems like an innocent
cover-up but this lie is used a lot in
comedies meant for adults it usually
means the husband is watching something
very inappropriate that he doesn't want
his wife to see saying mirages recording
is just the TV seems like a logical lie
but it is totally a reference to
husband's getting caught watching things
that would violate YouTube's Terms of
Service if you know what we mean it's no
wonder Elastigirl is so suspicious of
her husband insurance jokes after the
Super's are forced into hiding Bob goes
to work as an insurance agent he's not
supposed to help his clients as much as
he does and gives them insider
information on how to work the system to
get help his boss mr. Huff is a totally
obnoxious corporate making the company
money rather than helping
while these insurance jokes are not
inappropriate they are definitely meant
to make the adults laugh insurance can
be really frustrating and hard to
understand and you might hear lots of
adults complain about how businesses
like mr. Huff's in sheera care only care
about making money mr. huff straight up
says he doesn't care about the clients
coverage he only cares how bob is making
sure insurer ik air makes money when he
finds out bob has been giving extra
information on the inner workings of the
company he complains that they are
penetrating the bureaucracy we know
these are super boring jokes to most
kids we can guarantee you your parents
find it funny and relatable honestly
we're glad Bob gets fired he probably
didn't need to throw mr. Huff through
several walls we definitely don't
recommend doing that to your boss you
should be more flexible in the beginning
of the film we see mr. incredible change
out of his tuxedo and into his super
suit he thinks he has plenty of time
before some unknown event when he
confronts the purse robber Elastigirl
shows up and knocks out the bad guy the
two superheroes have some cute flirty
banter Elastigirl suggests that the two
partner up and work together but mr.
incredible insists he works alone what a
huge ego Elastigirl stretches all around
him even under his legs and tells him to
be more flexible this isn't just about a
double entendre it's a triple obviously
she means he needs to consider changing
his MO and she is definitely referencing
her super stretchy abilities but the way
they are flirting
we know she's also hinting at another
type of flexibility yep
she means being flexible behind closed
doors if you know what we mean it's
subtler than some of the adult humor in
this movie but it sure isn't kid
appropriate we were shocked to see they
already knew each other and we're
getting married just a few minutes later
they were pretending to barely know each
other just to keep things fresh they may
not always be the most kid-friendly
couple but they love each other a lot
drinking game and now for the funniest
adult joke in The Incredibles we were
shocked at the most inappropriate joke
in the movie seriously the writers
didn't even try to hide this one after
Syndrome releases the robot on to the
public and tries to make himself seem
like the hero The Incredibles have to
steal
rocket to go after him they encounter a
lot of guards they need to take out some
of the guards are watching TVs that show
the robot and syndrome we hear one guard
say every time they run take a shot and
then another guard pops open a bottle of
champagne yes these guards were playing
a drinking game they were trying to
drink way too many adult beverages we
cannot believe this was in a kids movie
what were they thinking drinking games
are not a good example for all the
children watching it can be super
dangerous but this joke was hilarious
and totally reminded us of college of
course syndromes guards weren't exactly
great examples for kids anyway we sure
hope there are no jokes glorifying the
dangers of drinking and Incredibles -
what are you most excited about Missy
Quall let us know in the comments and
these are the 10 funniest adult jokes in
The Incredibles if you like this video
be sure to subscribe and give us a big
thumbs up thanks for watching
[Music]